DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO
ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
MAY WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON WE ARE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS TO BE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION WE CAN NOW TURN TO
THE ITEMS BEFORE US TODAY-
WITNESSES MAY TESTIFY BY PHONE
OR FROM A WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. OR IN PERSON.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 844-721-7239 IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. NOW
WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO CALL
IN. THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE BASED
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
ALL FACE. WITH THAT WE CAN NOW
TURN TO THE ONE BILL BEFORE US
TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWO
SUMMONED BY SOMEBODY MEMBER
WHAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. YOU
MAY BEGIN.
WHAT IS YOUR RIGHT
IF. REWIND YEAH. WOULD YOU LIKE
ME TO REWIND. KALRA YEAH LET'S
GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A CORN
VERY QUICKLY MISTER INSPECTOR
CAN CALL THE ROLL. YES GABRIEL
OUT HERE GABRIEL PRESENT KILEY
KILEY PRESENT POWER K. R. K.
HAND PRESENT BENNETT YEAH
BENNETT PRESENT BERMAN. THAT'S
OUTDATED CORREA CAREER PRESENT
CHAO CHAO PRESENT CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM PRESENT GALLAGHER
HERE GALLAGHER PRESENT IRWIN.
BERMAN PRESIDENT WICKS HERE WE
EXPRESS AND WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND GIVE US YOUR
PRESENTATION ONE MORE TIME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
EMPLOYEES PERCENT EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN- THE THERE ARE
THREE COMPONENTS TO THE BILL OF
THE FIRST ASSURES THE
AVAILABILITY IN CALIFORNIA OF
NEW CANNABINOID RELATED DRUGS
AS THEY BECOME AVAILABLE FOR
MARKET FOLLOWING FDA APPROVAL
AND SUBSEQUENT RESCHEDULING
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. THE SECOND
ISSUE SIMPLY ALIGNS CALIFORNIA
LAW WITH EXISTING FEDERAL LAW
THAT EXEMPTS FROM FTA
SCHEDULING THOSE COMBINATION
DRUGS WHERE THE RATIO OF A
CONTROLLED DRUG COMPONENT TO
THE NINE CONTROLLED INGREDIENTS
QUALIFIES A DRUG PRODUCT FOR
THE EXEMPTION. THE FINAL ISSUE
IN THE ONE PRIMARILY UNDER
REVIEW TODAY RELATES TO ENSURE
IN OUR OWN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO THE
CURES DATABASE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF CONDUCTING MEANINGFUL DATA
DRIVEN RESEARCH THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED IN THE SENATE RESTORES
THE UC RESEARCHERS ACCESS
SECURES DATA UNDER THE EXACT
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXISTED PRIOR
TO THE NEW REGULATIONS. THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED WIDE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT MISS SAID
MRS SERRA HUCKLE A FROM THE
RECEIPT CALIFORNIA'S AVAILABLE
TO RESPOND AT ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. I UNDERSTAND YOUR
WITNESSES AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ALL SEE
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- SEEING
NINE IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
HAVE A OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES. THE
LATE JOHN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE N. ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
TAKE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SAYING
NON IN THE HEARING ROOM DO WE
HAVE ANY. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL ON THE PHONE LINE.
AND NOW AFTER IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MISTER
OPERATIVE WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. C. NONE. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORK
WITH MY STAFF AND UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
PROTECT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF THOSE LISTED IN
THE CARRIAGE DATABASE. WITH THE
BALLOT STRUCK BY THE RECENT
AUTHORS AMNDMENTS THE BILL
WILL ALLOW FOR THE UC'S TO
CONTINUE THEIR CRITICAL
RESEARCH INTO THE USE. OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES WHILE
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA'S. AT
CALIFORNIANS IMPORTANT PRIVACY
RIGHTS AND WITH THAT DOCTOR
WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KILEY. KILEY AYE BAR QUE. QUE
HAN HI BENNETT. BENNETT I
CARILLO. I CHAO CHAO I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I IRWIN-
WHEN I WICKS WICKS HI THAT. IS
OUT UNANIMOUS WITH ALL RIGHT
CONGRATULATIONS ARE BILLS OUT
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE. LATER WHAT EVER OKAY
HEARING IS ADJOURNED